I think we'll get this seminar started
and my name is Desmond Lachman and it's
my pleasure to welcome you to the AEI
this afternoon and I'm looking forward
to a very lively discussion about a
topic that is both important quantitive
easing by the world's major central
banks in late 2008 in response to the
global economic crisis and as interest
rates approached they lower zero bound
the Federal Reserve began its first
round of quantitative easing it did so
by buying mortgage-backed securities in
the secondary market this was followed
by two further rounds of quantitative
easing involving the purchase of large
amounts this time of both US Treasuries
and mortgage-backed securities by the
time that the Federal Reserve's
quantities in program ended in late 2014
that the Federal Reserve's balance sheet
had expanded from something like 800
billion dollars at the start of the
program to four and a half trillion
dollars by the end of the program the
Federal Reserve of course wasn't the
only central bank engaged in quantum
easing during this period we had indeed
the Bank of England the European Central
Bank and the Bank of Japan all engaged
in similar kind of programs with
differences of course but involving
purchases of assets in the secondary
market with inflation still very low in
both Japan and Europe both the Bank of
Japan and the European Central Bank are
continuing to do those purchases
although this week thus in the European
Central Bank has intimated that they
might be putting an end to that
process the actions of these central
banks has had a major impact on global
liquidity as evidenced by a 10 trillion
dollar increase in the combined size of
their balance sheets that in turn has
succeeded in producing a synchronized
global economic recovery however it has
also had a major impact on asset prices
and it has led to the substantial
compression of interest rate spreads
that could have implications for future
economic performance it struck me and
Alex Pollock who has helped me put this
seminar together there ten years on with
quantitative easing it would be a good
time to take stock of the results of
what is fair to say is the great
monetary policy experiment of our times
this last week's turbulence in global
financial markets stemming from events
in Italy and seeming to be spreading to
emerging markets including countries
like Brazil would seem to make the
seminar all the more timely the variety
of questions that might be addressed how
successful was the experiment with
Quantrill easing in avoiding deflation
and promoting economic recovery but not
to mention preventing us from slipping
into another great economic depression
what have been the unintended
consequences of those policies how
challenging will monetary policy
normalization and the reduction in the
size of the central banks balance sheets
be good quantitative easing be used in
combating the next recession when it
comes these are some of the questions
that deserve attention to address these
questions our first we'll have a
conversation with Chairman Ben Bernanke
and will immediately follow that with
conversation by discussion of a pair of
highly qualified experts
Chairman Bernanke will leave
at that stage and I ask you to please
remain seated to allow him to leave
easily before starting the conversation
with Jim blankie I should say how very
honored and fortunate we feel to have
him be with us this afternoon
Chairman Bernanke has unparalleled
policy economic policy experience having
served first as chair of the Council of
Economic Advisers and then to full terms
as chairman of the Federal Reserve in
the latter capacity he was the principal
architect of the Federal Reserve's
quantitative easing program as if that
were not enough Chairman Bernanke is
internationally recognized as a
preeminent scholar of monetary policy
with the deepest of knowledge of both
great oppression and the Japanese
economy so I can't imagine somebody more
qualified to be talking about this
subject please join me in welcoming
Chairman Bernanke
[Applause]
once again thank you very much for doing
this I thought maybe a good place to
start would be if you could just give us
a brief indication as to why were three
rounds of quantitative easing required
what were they trying to do how
successful were they thanks for inviting
me to your beautiful place here lovely
so as we've already introduced the idea
of why quantitative easing was
introduced in the first place I think
sometimes the discussion makes it sound
like this was something we did not a
whim you know but but in 2008 late 2008
early 2009 those fourth quarter of eight
in the first quarter of own I were the
two worst quarters of post-war US
history the economy was collapsing we
saw in when we gathered in March 2009
the FOMC we didn't know where the bottom
was going to be and we were seriously
concerned that we were facing a new
depression type situation the staff was
telling us that we needed 400 basis
points more of stimulus we had zero to
give because interest rates have been at
zero since the previous November so we
needed to do something and all members
of the FOMC from the most devilish to
the most talked aswer very strongly
agreed with this was the best option we
had so we undertook a very large program
we called it lsaps
large-scale asset purchases but the
press renamed it quantitative easing be
that as it may what it consisted of was
the Fed buying securities on the open
market and paying for them by creating
reserves in the banking system with the
idea of trying to reduce further
longer-term interest rates and create
more stimulus for the economy now I
think the the broad sense so there's a
question about benefits and cost right
so there was a cost-benefit analysis on
the benefits side again we hope that by
pushing down longer-term interest rates
we provide more stimulus help the
economy recover and I think the great
majority of studies and analyses you
yourself said this contributed to this
globally synchronized recovery the great
majority of studies suggest that this
was effective that it did ease financial
conditions did provide support for the
economy particularly QE one which came
at a time when markets were tremendously
disrupted condition but also the
additional rounds as well so I think on
the benefits side it did provide support
for an economy which otherwise appeared
to be hurtling toward the abyss now I
think it is important as we talk about
this then we get the right metric
because sometimes you hear people say
well this recovery was so weak growth
was not really very good compared to say
the recovery in the 1980s but that's not
a fair comparison for a couple of
reasons one is that the demographics of
the US economy are very different today
than they were in the 1980s in the 1980s
we had a growing labor force now we have
a labor force which is getting older
which is perhaps coming you know pretty
much flat so about a percentage point of
the difference in growth between the 80s
and recently just as accounted for by
the size of the population by the
demographics the other thing that we
didn't anticipate was that productivity
growth slowed a lot after the crisis and
studies that look at that suggest that
that process had already begun before
the crisis
so GDP growth was was modest but there
were factors involved that were
certainly outside of the feds control
including the demographics and the
productivity gains now the better metric
would be not growth but unemployment and
job creation and there the record is
very good the unemployment rate hit 10
percent in the fall of 2009 of course as
you know now it's below 4% it's been a
very steady decline in unemployment very
substantial job creation and of course
maximum employment is part of the feds
mandate on the other side
inflation was it was concerned that we
were concerned that with the depth of
the recession we might see very very low
inflation or even deflation of course
that didn't happen
inflation stay relatively close to the
feds 2% target and today is almost
exactly a 2 percent target so I think on
the benefits side has been it was
positive it contributed to the recovery
and gave us a tool where our traditional
short rate mechanism was no longer
available now I know there's a lot of
this discussions gonna be about two
costs we approach this very carefully
because we were concerned about
the cost but let me and we'll get into
that I'm sure but let me just say that
many of the costs that were anticipated
by outsiders simply have not happened
when we did the second round of
quantitative easing in November of 2010
we got a letter from Congress followed
up by a letter from a number of hedge
fund managers and economists imploring
its not to do this terrible thing and
among the things they were concerned
about was the possibility of
hyperinflation very high inflation a
collapse of the dollar or as they put it
debasing the currency and of course none
of those things have happened and and
indeed markets have functioned well and
the the concern about exit which we'll
talk about I'm sure while we certainly
have not exited yet the exit process has
begun the asset purchases ended in
October of 2014 now we're you know at a
process of where the balance she's
actually beginning to run off and of
course it hasn't finished but that also
has not shown itself to be a big problem
so far so let me just let me just sort
of conclude summarize and answer your
question which is you know quantitative
easing was an emergency measure the
effects are less certain and less well
understood than ordinary interest rate
management so it's not something that
the Fed or other central banks are going
to turn to routinely it's an emergency
measure however the next time that we
have a deep recession and short term
interest rates is zero which may well
happen you know I think it was something
that's in the toolbox and it's something
that you know central banks are willing
to use thank you that the whole process
of the Fed into totally uncharted
territory
knowing what you know today is there any
different way that you would have done
things or I'm thinking of the second
round of quantum easing the third round
quantitive easing I don't think we would
have been any less aggressive I think
you know as it was we were actually
fairly cautious because we didn't know
exactly what the side effects might be
etc and as a result perhaps the recovery
was even a bit slower than it might
otherwise have been but I think on the
other side I think we learned we have
learned a lot now about for example
communication
when the we first when I first chairman
I first Brewer did the idea that the
asset purchases might slow down I what I
said was very accurate and so on but as
you know we had what was called the
taper tantrum where markets over
extrapolated what I said this was 2013
in 2013 and created a lot of instability
Marcus it didn't really seem to harm the
US economy but did happen as well and
what we've seen since then is is much
more cautioned saying by the European
Central Bank and so on how they
carefully they communicate so that's one
of the drawbacks of quantitative easing
it's harder to communicate about it than
short-term interest rates so that's
certainly we've learned a lot about how
to do that through that well the other
thing that we experimented with was
whether to make quantitative easing a
fixed quantity or whether somehow to tie
it to the state of the economy and as we
moved along we began to make it more
conditional and say here's what we're
trying to achieve and purchases will
continue until sessions such happens so
I think you know we did learn how best
to implement it but I you know again I
think the overall feeling was that while
it is a uncertain tool and one that is
more difficult to use it's still
something worth having in the toolbox
yes sir he writes in reminding us that
there were a lot of people who feared
that this was really going to open the
floodgates there was going to be a lot
of money sloshing around that we would
have hyperinflation and all the rest but
something that strikes me is that we've
had a lot of asset price inflation so
you know for instance like if I look at
equity valuations today global equity
valuations you know certainly at the
beginning of this year they were only
experienced three times in the past
hundred years oils you know we've got a
lot of housing bubbles I'm thinking of
Australia Canada the United Kingdom
parts of the United States my question
is is that an inevitable part of want of
easing I mean should the Fed
be concerned about a surprise inflation
so some of the countries you mentioned
like Canada it didn't do quantitative
easing so well no but I'm thinking
they'll let I'm thinking that you know
what we're living in is we're living in
a global economy so if you've got the
Fed pumping in liquidity the one place
the European Central Bank the other this
money has to go somewhere
there are people already being forced to
so so in it is it is it's true that one
way which monetary policy works in
general is by encouraging risk-taking
and you know risk-taking is like ice
cream you know certain amount is good
beyond that maybe it's not so good right
and after a financial crisis people are
extremely cautious and extremely scared
and so encouraging some risk-taking that
point is probably a positive thing so
that's part of the mechanism it's not
the only part but it's part of the
mechanism and what it suggests is that
if you do have a period of very long a
very long period of low interest rates
that you do have to be cautious and one
of the things that I did at the Fed was
creating division which is now as big as
the monetary policy division of staff
which and a board committee whose job is
to monitor financial conditions and try
to make sure that you know what we can
address that with whatever tools we have
available and to keep the FOMC
well-informed about that but I think the
important thing a couple things I want
to say about this that's an extent that
this is a problem and I think there's
some you know I think caution suggest we
need to pay very close attention to
these developments it doesn't seem to be
particularly related to QE as opposed to
other kinds of monetary policy in
particular you know the just I'd like
the predictions of hyperinflation the
predictions of bubbles and crashes
associated with these QE programs have
not come true either
so for each them just give you a few
examples in 2010 this letter I mentioned
from the Congress they talked about
asset bubbles as being a major concern
at that time the Dow Jones was less than
12,000 now it's 25,000 I think a lot of
that gain is not bubble I think a lot of
it reflects genuine economic growth and
also low interest rates and taking those
two things into account it's not obvious
that stocks are wildly overvalued
they're a little bit of over value but
not wildly likewise in 2013 2012-2013
Jeremy Stein a governor for whom I
tremendous respect was talking about
these issues and he was talking about
concerns about credit bubbles
at that time five years ago there's a
lot of talk about how soon as the Fed
well maybe things are okay now but as
soon as the Fed begins stops asset
purchases and begins to exit we're gonna
have a crash and that was of course we
stopped asset purchase in 2014 and the
exit began last year so yes it's
possible that at some point there'll be
a problem but again just the Fed is
looking at this very carefully
monitoring it and secondly we've we've
seen tremendous benefits for the economy
so I'm not that concerned about it I
think that that actual assessments of
for example the stock market suggested
it's not while they overvalued in any
case you know it seems to most of the
gains that are related to the process
the economy's made I guess you know the
concern that I have is that we're not
just talking about maybe some asset
markets being overvalued but we talking
about credit spreads having been
incredibly compressed you know to levels
where it might not be reflecting the
risk of default so you know for instance
just to give you a good example you know
if you just take a look at emerging
markets you know merging market
corporates this last six years or so
they've increased their borrowing from
10 trillion dollars to twenty five
trillion dollars and the spreads are now
at the lowest level that they've been
more less historically you know my
concern is that the jury might still be
out you know because while the Fed has
stopped the quantum releasing the Bank
of Japan and the the European Central
Bank or stole added you know so oh
you're not concerned that you know
spreads when they widen that that could
cause some kind of dislocation during
financial my again so you do have to pay
attention to this and I think it's
important for the Fed one of the things
we learned in the crisis was that it
wasn't enough for each regulator to look
at their own little segment of the
market we did have to have a macro view
and the Fed and other regulators have
taken a much more macro scopic view of
this and it remains to be seen you know
I think again we have had this
tremendous benefit I you know the point
I guess the point I would leave you with
is this that that if you think about
regular regular monetary policy with
short-term interest rates it works very
much the same channels as quantitative
easing and there so if you believe that
monetary policy should be used to try to
help stabilize the economy you can't
really argue the quantitative easing is
somehow in a different category it works
through more or less the same mechanisms
but might the problem be that what's
occurred this time around is too much of
a burden has been placed on monetary
policy you know that's a more
appropriate way to have dealt with this
would have had a better balance between
fiscal and monetary policy in the sense
that it had there been additional kind
of fiscal stimulus or the helicopter
money that at one stage you propounded
the Fed wouldn't have been forced to go
in four-corner phasing and then cause
people to take a huge amount of risk so
again I think it remains to be seen
whether undue amount of risk has been
taken I think that remains to be seen
but on your main point about fiscal
policy I agree 100% and I said this all
the time I begged Congress in 2014 not
to raise taxes and cut spending as they
did it was the wrong time to do that but
generally speaking Congress was not
cooperating and and given that they were
doing what they were doing the Fed had
to take that is given and do what they
could right just in terms of
normalization that what the feds done
you know which seems to me to be
eminently sensible is they've set
themselves a path by which they're going
to be reducing the size of the balance
sheet you know we're running over 20
billion for three months and then 30
billion and so on and it eventually
reaches 50 billion but since they set
that path what's happened is for
whatever reason the Trump administration
has decided to have a fiscal stimulus at
this late stage in the cycle
my question is does that change the
calculus in some kind of way how does
the fact that you've got a physical
stimulus now you know what it makes the
feds job more difficult all around
because what you're getting is a
stimulus at the very wrong moment that
the economy is already at full
employment so you're getting hit by a
big stimulus which I'm the current law
we'll see what happens with its renewed
or not but in current law it's gonna hit
the economy in a big way this year and
next year and then in 2020 the wily
coyote is gonna go off the cliff and
it's gonna look down and they'll be
that'll be essentially withdrawn at that
point so the Fed has got a much more
difficult job to try to maintain
non-inflationary full employment over
the next three or four years given this
strong stimulus at this unusual time
followed by some withdrawal accidental
incidental withdrawal of stimulus and a
couple years from now but does it change
the balance between what the Fed should
be doing you know in terms of full term
interest rates as opposed to running off
the balance sheet in theory the fact
that the government the federal
government is issuing all this
additional debt might cause you to think
about that combination it's true but the
problem is as I talked about before is
that communicating about the balance
sheet is just very hard and as always
the risk the markets will misunderstand
you the Fed is very very happy with the
fact that they were able to announce
this unwind plan and get it going
without any kind of market disruptions
whatsoever and so if there's a very very
high bar for them to change because they
are afraid that if they begin to you
know vary the pace or make a conditional
in various ways so they'll create
uncertainty and volatility in financial
markets so in theory you're right but I
think that the feds view is that they're
so satisfied with how this has been
communicated and how this process has
begun they don't want to tinker with
that at all possible right but I guess
you know if we look back to 2017 you
know something that surprised me was
that at the beginning of 2017 the Fed
set for itself an interest rate path you
know more or less and then it basically
didn't change that interest rate path
for
who knows how long 15 months or so but
my question is is that appropriate when
you have a whole bunch of things
happening you know for start we had
since Trump became present stock prices
went up by 25% housing prices went up by
6% that's like an 8 trillion dollar
increasing wealth on top of that the
dollar depreciates by 10 percent and if
that's not enough we then get the fiscal
stimulus yet we had the same interest
rate part you know not sure what it is
that I'm missing well first the interest
rate paths are what's called the dot
plot this is the information that comes
out it'll come out next week the
quarterly meeting that the Fed sort of
gives these these projections so it's
important to understand that first of
all these are not official committee
projections they are simply the
accumulation of individual participants
who are giving their own personal view
and moreover it's not any kind of
commitment it's just here's our best
guess right now so so this is not a
program where the Fed is saying is what
we're definitely going to do and we
won't change from this this is really
just our best guess right now and of
course they change as the circumstance
has changed now what has changed in 2017
in particular was that inflation was
surprisingly low and the Fed is trying
to get inflation up to its target and is
actually quite comfortable with a mild
overshoot of the target and so they were
adjusting their their policies as they
go is that perhaps a little dangerous
you know in the sense that I don't know
whether academic views have changed but
in what I learn from Milton Friedman I
thought that what he indicated was that
monetary policy works with long and
variable lags waiting for the inflation
to reach your targets before adjusting
the policy doesn't that create the
danger that you're gonna be too late
well we just make a very strong caveat
here I'm not gonna second-guess my
successors here so whatever I'm saying
you know just try to interpret how
they're talking about it
okay so what they would say first that
they have been raising rates I mean they
have raised rates six times or whatever
it is so that and they would did that
with inflation below target in exactly
for the point you made that they wanted
to anticipate this process in terms of
worrying about a big overshoot of course
that's a forecasting issue and they're
trying to figure that out but the Fed
believes and again I'm just reporting as
I understand their thinking the Fed
believes that the so-called Phillips
curve is very flat meaning that even
though unemployment is now below their
estimate of the sustainable level
inflation will not go up very much from
here so that's their forecast obviously
if that turns out to be wrong they'll
have to adjust one way or the other it's
going back to the question of increase
in wealth how much of an impact does
that have on the economy you know that
if equity prices go up house prices go
up that there's a permanent increase in
wealth is the estimate around about four
cents on the dollar store well in play
probably yes but let me go back a second
which is I'm you know before you were
asking me about the feds influences on
asset prices and worrying about asset
prices that are too high or spreads that
are too weak and I think that what the
Fed would say is that the effects of
miss pricings etc if they are if they
are miss pricings we don't know but if
they are depends a lot on who owns and
how leveraged those owners are so to
answer your question if you look back at
the stock market crash of 1999-2000 that
was an enormous decline in stock prices
and all we got was a relatively mild
recession that lasted for eight months
whereas in 2008 you had a much smaller
asset class subprime mortgages were a
tiny asset class and yet because they
affected all these securities that were
in turn held by highly leveraged players
including large banks and investment
banks it was enough to create this
massive crash that hurt the economy so I
think going back to your point about
about say stock prices I think the Fed
is pretty relaxed about stock prices if
stock prices were to move again because
they are held primarily by unleveraged
asset holders
the implications for the broader economy
are not so great
likewise there's the banking system in
the core of the financial system today
is much stronger than it was in 2007
much more capital for example and so the
risks of a of a sharp correction and say
commercial real estate prices creating a
crisis of the sight type we saw a decade
ago seems much lower and of course you
never know and it's important to be
continuously vigilant but those are the
kinds of considerations that the Fed
would be looking at yeah but I guess
that a concern that one must have today
as opposed to 2008 is the whole easiness
of monetary policy globally has been
associated with an increase in levels of
debt that we haven't seen before so you
know for instance if I look at the IMF
numbers that indebtedness global
indebtedness today is something like 30
or 40 percentage points of GDP higher
than it was in 2008 you know so if
there's a lot of mispricing and you get
correction you know we're dealing with a
lot more debt I take the point that the
leverage could be limited but there's
got to be concern that you know we get a
rerun of say something like 1998 you
know where we have an LTCM or two and
then we find that the bank saw it's not
legitimate to add together all different
kinds of debt into one number which is
what you're doing there so you have to
break it up so for example a lot of the
debt the IMF is concerned about is debt
in China okay and and and China has used
a lot of debt as a development technique
they essentially use bank lending as a
substitute for fiscal policy it's a very
different proposition you know that
those that debt is a very different
proposition from US household debt which
is actually way down from the crisis the
critical levels of debt in the u.s.
first household debt is way down bank
leverage is way down because bank
capital is much higher those are two
critical components corporate leverage
is up
and that's something that the Fed
noticed in their minutes for the last
meeting but corporations are extremely
profitable in cash-rich right now and
and they're not particularly exposed to
these asset price movements you're
talking about so it's very important
when you talk about debt in general that
you not just add together all these
different components but that you look
at who is indebted to whom and what
assets are supporting that debt and in
situations where you have highly risky
assets held by highly leveraged and
critical borrowers that's that's a
different proposition in the United
States at least I don't think that's
currently the situation yeah well I
guess we don't want to drift into Europe
but you know Italy it has to be
concerned that you know here we're
talking about the third largest
sovereign bond market you're talking
about something like two and a half
trillion dollars of debt and you know
the government doesn't look to to steady
but I see we're running out of time let
me if you'll allow me let me just ask
one final question if we do go into
recession how should we really be
dealing with that next time around
because it looks like you know I just
phrased the question a little bit more
it looks like because of the Trump
budget move you know you're ready using
our fiscal space you know if a recession
came pretty soon you interest rates
would still be at a very low level how
do you see the what kind of policy
response well one would hope that fiscal
responsible but you're right that the
deficits we have now make it all the
more difficult both economically and
politically to do more on the fiscal
side so let's imagine for the sake of
argument that the Fed is you know the
only responder to this decline well it
does have first of all it does have some
space to cut rates and that would be
useful the second tool that has is
what's called forward guidance so it
could make promises or forecasts about
keeping rates low for a period of time
or into a certain set of circumstances
obtains those two things are pretty
powerful and probably could address a
moderate slowdown a somewhat bigger
recession then that's where quantitative
easing might once again become a
possibility again I want to be clear
this is not a routine tool and not one
that's gonna be used routinely every
time the economy slows down but if we
did have a serious recession which drove
short-term interest rates to zero then
the Fed would certainly look at that so
those are the tools really that it has
the other thing that it's talking about
generally is whether or not it would
make sense over the medium term not
immediately but over the medium term to
change its framework from the current
inflation targeting framework to a
framework which essentially allows for
overshoots of inflation when you're
coming out of a recession there's
something so called price level
targeting and it has the property that
if you have a period like we had the
last few years where inflation is below
target for a long time there's a makeup
period where the Fed overshoots for a
while we'll try to compensate and if you
do that and that markets understand that
that'll give you a little bit of
additional power as well but basically
the tools it has are rate cuts forward
guidance and quantitative easing if
necessary and beyond that I mean I don't
think there's a lot in the toolbox but
how about a helicopter money you know
would that not you know I I would have
thought that one of the advantages of
going the helicopter money route would
we would be that we don't have the
income distribution or problems that we
might be associated with you know in the
sense that one wouldn't be bidding up as
prices that it looks like it's the wall
street types that are gaining and the
mainstream people already there's a
perception kind of problem if you had
the helicopter money you know it would
look like it was a lot fairer then the
quantity wouldn't actually be might look
that way but in any case we're pretty
far from that and I honestly I don't
really have a lot of confidence that US
government could manage that kind of
coordination frankly I just don't see
hopefully happening as a practical
matter I thought the Air Force might be
able to do an Air Force maybe yeah it's
possible
with that sometime thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
I thought the chair just left oh sure
Oh absence of chairs I was just gonna
say a word you sit next to me because
you're going to be first and then even
if you said second second yeah
yeah thank you for your forbearance I'm
please say that we've really got a very
strong panel to discuss questions that
weren't discussed or perhaps to give us
different views on the matters that I
asked the Chairman and what I've asked
to each speaker to do is to talk for
about 15 minutes and then you know
hopefully there'll be time for Q&A
I really am pleased that we've assembled
a very strong panel who's got real
expertise on this matter
the first that was to speak is governor
Kevin Worf who's presently a
distinguished fellow at the Hoover
Institution and he teaches at Stanford
Graduate School he's more than qualified
to discuss quantum easing having a
served as governor at the Fed between
2006 and 2011 during the period in which
quantum easing was put in place prior to
serving at the Fed he was a special
assistant to the president for economic
policy and was executive secretary for
the White House National Economic
Council Kevin will be followed by Steven
Roach who's presently a senior fellow at
Yale University's Jackson Institute of
global affairs and a senior lecturer at
Yale School of Management his specially
well-placed to provide us with a market
perspective on quantitative easing
having for many years worked in the
markets he was formerly a chairman of
Morgan Stanley Asia and the firm's chief
economist for the bulk of his 30-year
career there we've got then Joseph
ganyan who's a senior fellow at the
Peterson Institute who's also got deep
experience at the Federal Reserve where
he served as an associate director of
the feds division for international
affairs and he's also worked at the US
Treasury and last but not least is
Alex Pollock who helped me put the
seminar together and who has many years
of banking sector experience so we can
get another market view on quantum
easing
alex is presently a distinguished senior
fellow with the Austrian Institute
previously Alex I had the good fortune
of having him as my colleague at the
American Enterprise Institute and prior
to joining the AEI Alex was president
and CEO of the Federal Home Loan Bank of
Chicago from 1991 to 2004 I've given the
panelists a choice as to whether they
want to talk from the lecture and all
from where they're sitting right now and
Stephen might have to leave us just a
little bit before the end so with that
introduction I'm looking forward to
hearing what the panelists have to say
guys thank you not just in monetary
policy but under Arthur Brooks
leadership really moved the ball a lot
on a range of issues so it's certainly a
pleasure to be here you heard in those
first 30 minutes from a from a great
great man I have worked with him mostly
in the arena for some dark days in the
financial crisis I'll give you some
reflections on that there were two
things that that been said that I agree
with one was that QE was a quote
emergency measure which begs the
question what it's been doing for the
last several years which don't feel like
an emergency he also said that it's
worth having in the toolbox and because
I am somewhat modest about what we know
of what's going to happen in the global
economy over the next several years I
agree with that
I don't share many of the other views
that were expressed so here's what I'm
gonna try to do in fifth
ten minutes I've got some prepared
remarks because old habits die hard and
when were fed governors they make us
reduce everything to writing just some
prepared remarks which are circling
about I think they're outside I will
speak from them but I will speak loosely
now I'm not going to speak as loosely as
Ben did when he made the Wiley coyote
reference of what happens the economy in
2020 that is decidedly not what Fed
Chairman or governor supposed to at any
point in their careers but he was felt
very comfortable here among friends so
I'm gonna begin with a quote from from
the CEO of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation just to try to set the tone
of where I come out here's what sue
Desmond held and once said whereas
skepticism and uncertainty have always
been the heart and soul of science
confidence in certainty or the coin of
the realm in much of today's public
discourse so I'm honored to be here as I
mentioned Ben was that academic star
whose remarkable contributions in the
crisis blew most of us away I was
fortunate to be on his at his side
tasked with trying to distill some of
these market signals and to try to lead
a SWAT team under his leadership to
respond to the crisis and when the panic
showed very few signs of abating I was
struck by this man's calmness his wisdom
and most of all his humility about what
we knew and what we didn't know those
character traits including humility are
no less essential today and unlike some
of qyz loudest voices you hear fierce
attacks from QE critics and zealous
support from others Ben and I were
actually present at the creation in Dean
at Justin's famous words so neither of
us have very clean hands I need to admit
that neither of us perhaps have our
thoughts sufficiently detached from the
decisions we made to offer a perfected
judgment on QE ten years hence I think
it's important that we recognize that
and you observe that in us you can judge
whether our launch of QE to defeat the
panic makes us good scribes of this next
draft of history you can judge whether
my co-authorship with Ben of QE won in
the darkest days
we were at sea in 2008 and my decision
to get off the boat two years later to
approve of qe2 with him and to leave the
Federal Reserve was either wise or
foolhardy QE this entire discussion
today seems to be getting considerably
less attention than the interest rate
debate which is raging at the Fed and
among pundits as if the questions around
QE are as certain as resolved as some
would have us believe whether the FOMC
raises rates two or three times 50 or 75
basis points this year strikes me as
very incidental to economic growth and
employment this year next and while
they're gonna put out new dots that been
described next week which market seemed
to be quite impressed by it's not
obvious to me that those dots and the
relative caricature of participants as
hawks and doves based on whether they
have two or three more dots this year is
all that important the monetary lessons
of this arrow will be found elsewhere
the real money for verbally speaking is
on central bank balance sheets so next
let me just go back a decade let's just
do a little bit of time traveling if
with a snap of our fingers you could
eavesdrop on the discussions we had in
Ben's office a decade ago you would hear
us around this time in 2008 start to
conceive of the remnants of QE one you
would not have heard any great
confidence from us about what its
effects would be what its channels would
be how we'd get out of it nor would you
have heard us elevate the importance of
QE relative to the eleven or twelve
other monetary policy tools we launched
on Sunday nights in the depths of the
crisis and you would certainly have
heard no inkling from the likes of us
that a decade later the world's central
banks would be killing ten trillion
dollars of this stuff and would be
adding in 2018 hundreds of billions of
more of net global QE around the world
so if you travel back in time though
from this moment to that and you
informed us where we are our faces would
have looked more ashen than they did at
the time our spirits more sullen if you
confronted us with
acts of QE today we would have figured
then that would those facts our monetary
experiment must have failed a decade of
Malaya's must have ensued fiscal
dominance must have prevailed and the
unwind of QE proved impossible what
would be particularly shocked to hear
new reporting of from 2018 to 2008 we
may be shocked to hear of the
juxtaposition of peak QE in 2018 amid a
global economic boom so what if you had
time traveled not back ten years but you
went back eh
we're back in Ben's office where I spent
three years eating breakfast lunch and
dinner
besides this great thinker and great man
if you went back eight years from to
about today you'd find us in the middle
of a difficult internal debate where he
pushed each other then was spectacular
and pushing all of us on the relative
risks and rewards of employing wartime
tools in what seemed to us to be
beginning a peacetime you would hear me
ask a colleague what should we do if qe2
succeeds and he told me then what we
should do more of it made some sense I
then asked a dear colleague what would
should we do if qe2 which were on the
verge of launching didn't succeed he
hesitated he shrugged his shoulders he
said we might well have to do more of it
a theory deserves special scrutiny if it
can't be disproved what began as an ad
hoc necessary risky Fed policy response
to stem of panic morphed into something
else including something like standard
operating procedure the regime changed
but it is an obvious to me how much QE
changed along with it you would have
thought that a decade when Alex and
Desmond in the group said a decade
should be long enough and will assess
how that QE experiment worked you would
have thought a decade be sufficient to
provide strong compelling evidence of
the wisdom or folly of our QE seriatim
experiment but it's not for the central
bank community evaluating QE we're still
in the thick of history the mission
accomplished signs that we he
being trotted out by some advocates
should be stowed away I am open-minded
that they can be trotted out another
time but as we sit here today at the
decade mark there is no QED to QE so
what about my preliminary judgments with
that bias and that pitch on humility
policymakers confront the knowledge
problem which is dog scientists even
economists come scientists for millennia
central bankers have no control groups
and with QE we neither of the benefit of
historical comparison nor a natural
experiment because most the rest the
world central bankers replicated remade
QE policies as their own
so these heavy heaps of humility let me
offer several judgments but let me
restate that these are unprovable at
this remove maybe when we come here ten
years from now we can judge the wisdom
of either Ben's remarks or mine but I'll
take a shot first contrary to some of my
conservative brethren when I was in the
engine room would been concocting QE one
and thinking it would work I'm here to
say that QE one was a success as far as
we can tell but unlike what you hear
from others it didn't work in isolation
as a panic antidote it worked in concert
however haphazardly with other fed
talking tools on offer and it probably
been worked directly fed purchases in QE
one brought a needed liquidity to
illiquid markets because it crowded in
private capital our liquidity provision
bolstered market prices but the higher
asset prices were largely the result of
improved liquidity inducing higher
volumes better matching of bids and
offers which is a different story than I
often hear about qyz successors second
in my judgment qe2 and its successors
may have had a small positive impact on
employment and output but assigning a
couple of tenths of GDP a fraction of a
percent of the unemployment rate
annually to incremental QE provisioning
is outside the confidence interval of
this profession increases in consumption
facilitated by lower rates and higher
asset price
may or may not have ultimately been
offset by lower consumption the
out-years and lower non-residential
fixed investment which throughout the
period remained to anachronistically
week in fact the acceleration and output
the acceleration output in employment in
recent quarters including a big pickup
in business capex may well be a function
of changes both in fiscal policy and
monetary policy including some clarity
about the Fed's QE exit plan third been
said that we know how QE works and the
channels work much the same way as
interest rates I'm not so sure the
effect of QE on financial assets is
considerably more significant in my view
than its effect on real assets in the
real economy stocks credit and other
risk assets currently trade at
materially higher values than they would
absent global QE some leading economists
many leading policymakers seem to
believe that QE is now somehow
immaterial the financial asset prices
they believe that stocks and other risks
assets are trading at fair and reliable
prices in a durable equilibrium it's
funny that was largely the feds view in
the mid to late 2000s when the Great
Moderation was the consensus moniker for
benign conditions and a rosy outlook
many of us myself included deserve some
bit of blame for assenting then to the
notion that the US was approaching some
kind of end of economic history that the
professions knowledge was now so
advanced so it's that significant
economic shocks could be avoided as I
hear things broadly I fear were mistaken
again forth the real returns to
household wealth which Desmond queried
Chairman Bernanke around have proven
significantly larger than the household
income QE in my view is a material part
of the inequality story the
distributional effects of QE across
households are significant despite
all-time highs in stock prices and house
prices household net worth since 2007 is
down for all
income groups except for the top 10% net
worth for the top decile is up an
average of 27% for the middle deciles
it's down 20 to 30% in real terms that
does not ask or answer the question
whether we should have done QE last time
whether we should do it next time but I
think it suggests we shouldn't hide from
the data fifth and finally inflation
which you heard in the earlier colloquy
discussed is a poor barometer of the
wisdom or folly of qe2 and its
successors prevailing theories of
inflation dynamics are not sufficiently
robust to allow policymakers like us to
fine-tune the Delta between current
inflation and inflation targets based on
incremental stock or flow of QE when I
hear policymakers proudly announce that
inflation is only one point seven six
and not two point zero zero really
wonder what we're doing talking about
all these decimal points too often
inflation is used as a cudgel against QE
skeptics and to those who predicted
hyperinflation they've been referenced a
couple of times an effective rhetorical
cudgel indeed but for those of us who
are actually in the arena alongside of
him the concerns we voiced are not so
readily dismissed my overriding concern
about continued QE both then in 2010 and
now involves the miss allocations of
capital in the economy and the miss
allocations of responsibilities and on
government miss allocations seldom
operate however under their own name
they choose other names to hide behind
they tend to linger for years in plain
sight until they emerge with force at
the most inauspicious of times and do
unexpected harm to the economy so
finally let me just in the interest of
time frame the big fight I think in four
big questions before turning over the
next panelist so what really separates
qyz fiercest advocates from its
unabashed critics which I consider
myself neither policymakers evaluate the
benefits of risks and risks of QE
differently at different points in the
cycle these different judgments are
often
describe the differences in forecast
differences in weightings but I think
that explanation is a bit misleading for
questions it strikes me helps sort out
the substantive differences among us
I'll just simply ask the four questions
and allow you to repair to the more
written remarks for the answers first
how important are price signals in my
view price signals are everything price
signals are precious so when we decide
to mute price signals it better darn
well be worth it and in the depths of
the crisis my judgment was it was worth
it and during the times of somewhat
greater peace and prosperity
I think hiding a price signal of the
most important risk asset anywhere in
the world the 10-year Treasury bond is a
more tricky endeavor but if you don't
believe price signals are the end-all
be-all
if you don't think price volatility
volume the rest are telling you much and
you want to make judgments based on data
that comes from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics in the Department of Commerce
well that's fine
but I think these price signals matter a
lot and I don't know how to conduct
monetary policy as a central bank
without them second how well do
policymakers understand and incorporate
individuals decision making my answer to
that is not well but there's incredible
work happening in the profession to do
that better this economy is incredibly
complex
the idea that a newfangled policy like
QE can be understood in terms of what
that does to decision-maker strikes me
as a hot I'll give you a quote from some
one of my favorite economists Richard
Rees who says forecasting when the
forecasts caused changes in policy which
then make people change their choices
which in turn makes it required to
revise the forecast is it overly hard
third and it's not one that should be
easily reduced and I wish we had a model
that could do that and the Fed and it is
to 840 PhD economists I hope are working
on that model but I'd be surprised if
they haven't ready for primetime third
how should the Fed best accomplish its
objectives well if you think that the
data that we're relying on is excellent
repression about economic developments
we're confident of the effects of our
choices I have no problems with
fine-tuning GDP employment inflation
targets but if you believe what I
believe which is the knowledge problem
is real it requires us to believe a few
things one that business cycles and
financial cycles are real and it can
Cline's us to want to direct the feds
considerable monetary capabilities to
offset major disturbances in the economy
we need to prepare ourselves for those
focus on the tails not the median that's
my view but that is not a consensus view
in the profession and the fourth and
final question in closing how durable is
the Fed status and responsibilities if
we think the Fed is a permanent feature
of our government and you've got really
nothing to worry about the Fed gets some
right gets some wrong but no one would
dare take on the independence and
credibility of the Fed but of course
American history tells us this is our
third experiment of a central bank and
without going into detail it's our third
because the first two didn't work out so
well so in conclusion I come to this
discussion as a candid friend both of
the topic of QE where I have sullied my
hands as a huge admirer of Ben Bernanke
and reappraise call for little humility
given what we've endured we are not to
depart from today's debate and repair to
the ideological conformity of our own
Ben Bernanke chose me to sit next to him
before the crisis ever got going
persuaded the president I was just the
guy to help with markets and he knew
that my instincts on almost every
question were a bit different than his
and he wanted me by his side for that
period that is the sign of a leader so
if we decide today that we've got it all
figured out that we just hang around
with everyone else who agrees with us
then I would suggest the deliberative
process would be worse off the future
decision making worse off and we need to
reverse that so I'd call for the same
comparable mindset that Ben had in 2006
when we left the White House to go to
the Fed to return to us now a decade
after QE thank you
thank you this absolutely thank you very
much Kevin for such a thought-provoking
discussion of the issue Stephen thanks
echo Kevin it's a real pleasure to be
here in front in front of such a
distinguished group of you out there as
well as those who are on the stage and
who have departed from the stage and I
was particularly struck by Kevin's
remarks I have spent a lot of my time
writing about and now teaching about the
Chinese economy and your your
self-criticism that we just heard would
make the the Chinese very proud they're
they're particularly good at that I say
that with tongue-in-cheek certainly
quantitative easing is deserving of this
retrospective look sure it's too early
to draw firm and hard conclusions but I
think you know goes down in history as
the boldest experiment in the history of
modern central banking the only thing
comparable that I can think of quite
honestly is the anti inflation campaign
under Paul Volcker in 79 and 80 but that
was conventional this was unconventional
and therefore untested you're gonna get
probably a lot of different lists from
each of us Kevin ended with a list of
four I'm just going to highlight what I
think are five lessons that are worth
thinking about in assessing QE as we
near this this great ten thing
nursery the first one pertains to
traction the link between Fed policy and
its congressionally mandated objectives
of maximum employment and price
stability it's already been said and I
would just echo the the first part of my
answer Kiwi one was successful it was
successful in arresting the worst part
of a wrenching financial crisis that
opposed grave threats to both dimensions
of the dual mandate I disagree with
Chairman Bernanke and I think I agree
with Kevin although he didn't quite say
this that the second and third rounds
qe2 and qe3 were less successful than QE
one and that raises the distinct
possibility that there were diminishing
returns to a QE traction I think the the
Fed operated under the erroneous
presumption that what worked in crisis
would work equally well post crisis and
I think there was a little bit of
rewriting history saying that that they
were comfortable with the idea that it
may not work as well going forward I
found that the Chairman's comments on
the metrics to judge QE were a little a
little puzzling and to some extent a
little bit defensive I think the idea
that
we should qualify real economic growth
post-crisis by demography and
productivity is a huge debate especially
since the productivity slowing may in
fact have been an outgrowth of the
crisis that the economy went through
it's pretty clear that the gdp path over
the last nine years plus of two percent
is about half the the norm of earlier
long cycles and to dismiss that
shortfall as being something outside the
purview of monetary policy is I think
something you can draw into question the
you know the numbers I think are pretty
clear that that QE two and three were
disappointing both from at least the
payback we're disappointing as it can be
seen from both the quantity and the
price dimensions of the Fed's monetary
policy transmission mechanism the
evidence on quantity do a
back-of-the-envelope calculation
yourself from September of 2008 to
November of 2014 the end of QE 3
successive QE programs added three point
six trillion dollars to the Fed's
balance sheet over that same exact
period nominal GDP was up two point nine
trillion so there was clearly a lot more
Kiwi injected into the system than was
reflected in the real economy looking at
the evidence on the impact of QE on the
price dimension of monetary policy I'm
left with the same
inclusion insofar as estimating its
impact on longer-term interest rates
namely the 10-year Treasury recent paper
written by my former colleague Dave
Greenlaw James Hamilton ethan Harris and
Kenneth West looked very carefully at
the impact of QE on 10-year Treasury
yields through their events studies
metric and drew raised serious questions
about the link between QE and 10-year
Treasury yield the second lesson I'll be
a little briefer here is a lesson of the
deals with the addictive beat behavior
between economic decision making and
balance sheet management by the central
bank aimed at supporting asset markets
to peace event of evidence here one the
excess liquidity that I just cited
obviously I think spilled over and
Desmond you were alluding to this in the
equity markets has also provided
valuation support to the bond market and
so to Kevin's point which is really
important that I agree with on price
discovery asset prices were shaped more
by monetary authorities than by the
fundamentals of the market and the
second piece of the addiction lesson is
the impact that wealth effects have on
real economic activity post crisis I
mean post crisis American consumers in
particularly rated by the job losses and
the recession needed the wealth effects
more than ever and with the lifeline of
support
in this dark period then then comes a
very difficult pain of withdrawal and I
think that's been increasingly the case
for the real side of the US economy but
also the case and again that just
underscore the point that Desmond was
making for capital inflows into foreign
economies and especially the impact of
those flows on QE distorted interest
rate spreads true at the taper tantrum
of 2013 along with more current
manifestations of that we're seeing in
Argentina in Brazil the third lesson
I'll just mention it because because
Kevin really did a terrific job of
laying it out his mounting income
inequality just remember one thing it's
pretty obvious wealth effects are for
the wealthy and we had a lot a lot of
wealth created forth and here's where I
certainly agree completely with what
Chairman Bernanke was alluded luding to
QE blurs the distinction between fiscal
and monetary policy and the mounting
debt burden of the United States
government is a little consequence today
in a zero interest rate environment but
make no mistake about it the debt
overhang is building hugely and as has
been alluded to several times earlier
today we'll be growing a good deal
further in the years ahead because of
these ill-timed late cycle fiscal
stimulus actions but over the the course
of the QE period from 2008 to 2017
public debt held by the federal debt
held by the public doubled from 39 to 70
6% and so you know in a zero interest
rate environment big deal no big deal
but when as rates start to normalize
maybe a bigger deal and America's fiscal
risks could then be unmatched my fifth
lesson and this is the one where I have
just as much respect as I have for Ben
Bernanke this is one where I'm seriously
at odds with him
and his predecessor intellectually and
that's the distinction between
short-term tactics and longer-term
strategy as the lender of last resort
the Fed deserves great credit for
stepping into the lurch and saving the
financial system from catastrophic
implosion in the depths of the crisis
the problem of course and I say this
with all due respect is is that the Fed
in my view under both the chairman
Greenspan and Chairman Bernanke
played a role and not an inconsequential
role in conducting condoning the
pre-crisis froth that took the system to
the brink and so this you know really
poses a profound and deep strategic
question did we want a reactive central
bank that is focused on cleaning up the
mess after a crisis unfolds or is it
preferable to have a proactive central
bank that is willing to move before a
crisis hits and lean against the
mounting excesses in asset markets this
debate over whether it's a lien or clean
as they call it continues to rage in
policy and academic circles and Chairman
Bernanke and chairman Greenspan our
cleaners and and they have been strongly
in favor of this reactive approach in
the case of Ben Bernanke as an academic
before he even came to Washington
there's obviously an important political
economy component to this
debate are independent central bank's
willing to impose a growth sacrifice on
society it's a price for some financial
stability it also bears on the bubble
spotting debate how do you know when
there's a bubble and therefore how do
you know when they intervene in asset
markets as difficult as those two
problems and questions are I think they
pale in comparison of the cost of
forgone output that has occurred in this
anemic post crisis recovery drawing
vindication from the supposed benefits
of QE by stressing the dreaded
counterfactual chaos and collapse sweeps
aside I think the perfectly legitimate
questions that can be asked about a
tougher and more disciplined central
bank that's not to argue that QE 1 was
not necessary in the depths of the
crisis but it does raise questions about
the subsequent commitment to these
different tranches of QE that were
argued as being essential for economic
recovery I worry about the feds
preference for glacial normalization I
worried about it in the early 2000s as
having set the stage for the financial
crisis of au 1809 and I worry about
today I worry about keeping monetary
policy in its emergency settings long
after the emergency has passed the the
point on inflation is a huge issue and
Kevin what was the word you used a
cultural cudgel yes I'm worried it's
more of a foil inflation you know when
inflation is low central banks are
forgiven for anything because they say
you know what's the big deal you know we
have a price stability target and and
you know we can get away with it
and I'm not sure that's something that
that history will judge all that kindly
so my bottom line is thank you for the
invitation
I love anniversaries you know 10-year
anniversary's are really special and you
know I look forward do have to leave a
little early soon I'm gonna miss taking
a bite out of that delicious anniversary
cake that I saw in the hall I we can
only hope that we don't need another
unconventional policy experiment like QE
but I think in the event of another
crisis we need to be pretty careful
about looking at the shortcomings of
this bold experiment and I have a great
concern that if we try it again and this
has become a normal part of the toolkit
it may not work out as well next time
thank you thank you
[Applause]
so I have rights so I hope someone will
put them up are they up while we're
waiting for the slides I guess I can get
started but it would be nice if the
slides were up let me let me just start
by thanking Desmond for inviting me and
this is obviously a hugely important
topic for us to be discussing and there
we go thank you thank you huge important
topic for us to be discussing and this
is a great group of people I am going to
be aligning myself more with Chairman
Bernanke than my panelists somewhat
Kevin may remember I was also there at a
lower level of the Federal Reserve at
the time everything was happening and
and as our call each of the officers had
their own special program to work on and
mine was QE so my job was to figure out
what the hell would do anyway so I start
from the premise of that and no one has
really challenged it so far so maybe
I'll get away with it but that we are in
a world of in which the interest rates
have fallen securely for various reasons
and I would point to the fact that I
looked actually some data we have not
had in the United States such a long
period of such low and stable inflation
since at least the 30s if we ever had
you have to go back that far because
then we had some deflation true
deflation but that's how far you have to
go back so we haven't really it's it's
it's a trend decline in inflation a
trend decline in growth rates maybe some
it was endogenous agenda we can argue
about that but for whatever reason
potential growth is down certainly
demographics can't be argued with
that's exogenously the system aging
populations raising saving and this is
happening all around the world not just
the u.s. so low interest rates are a
global phenomenon and yet we know that
the existence of paper
currency implies that we can't push
interest rates significantly below zero
now it's true that in Europe and Japan
we've gone a little bit below zero or
for some rates but if you actually look
at what's going on it's pretty clear
that that's reached the limit of what
can be done and we haven't even got to
minus one so basically the lesson I
learned there is you can't go
significantly below zero and yeah we
know that when we get into recessions
Taylor type rules often call for very
large cuts and interest rates and Janet
Yellen famously said joined the March
2009 FOMC meeting that her rule her
version of the Taylor rule called for
setting the Fed Funds rate at minus six
just not possible been recently just now
said he thought that some other models
the Fed had were saying - 450
so for four point five rather so you
know that's just not possible so what do
you do so I won't spend time on this you
could ban paper currency which then
would allow the Fed to set the rate as a
negative visit once and just follow
those Taylor rules right below zero I
think that's just not feasible I would
like to do that if we could but I don't
think that's physical feasible for many
reasons and I won't talk more about it
second thing you could do is for
guidance which Ben mentioned that's
basically saying if you're at zero or a
little below zero you try to persuade
people you'll stay there longer that
helps a little bit but it's not enough
you can't really go that far into the
future so let me continue on you could
raise the inflation target no one here's
talked about that that clearly would
work in the sense that if we had a much
higher inflation rate then when we lower
the nominal rate to zero we have a big
negative real rate and the real rate is
what matters to the economy but there's
you know raising inflation but much
above two would have significant costs
which we have to accept and would we
really want to do that now been proposed
a version in which you switch to a price
level target the zero bound and he
explained that I think that makes some
sense
back to that I don't think this is
enough and I think he implied he didn't
think this is enough so on to finally
quantitative easing now the idea here
again some people said is but I guess I
have a slightly different view of it
than some people here the the idea is
that when the policy rate that you do
control it's a risk-free short-term rate
when that gets to zero other rates are
still above zero other yields are still
above zero you can buy those assets and
push their rates of return down and that
will help stimulate the economy and
boost spending I think this this is
something this is what I was working at
the time to try to figure out how much
that would be and we have very little to
go on it's true
I think Kevin was right to say that that
we need to be humble and you know about
how certain we can be about our policy
actions and how they affect the economy
but we're forced to try you know whether
you're proud or you're humble you have
to as a policymaker do the best that you
think you can do and that was what we
tried to do since we launched this
program there's been just a explosion of
research on this topic and not just in
the US but around the world and not just
the event studies which some people
mentioned which are very fragile in
terms of you know how you specify the
events but there's also regression
analysis and looking back in history and
people look back into 60s there's a lot
of ways of getting at how QE works that
are very clever out there and the
amazing thing is that you 90 plus
percent of these studies all agree and
find a relatively reasonable range of
the effects there was one study
mentioned that came out after my survey
which did find a much smaller effect it
was an event study which I think made an
unfortunate choice of events which
didn't make sense but by far I mean it's
the vast majority of studies all agree
on a positive effect in a reason
which is very unusual for those of you
who do empirical research to get
everyone to agree so quickly and when I
talk to central bankers around the world
the effectiveness of QE is just widely
accepted and it's many people just think
it's now going to be a routine tool so
this is where I disagree with my
colleagues now someone mentioned and
many people have mentioned while QE 1
clearly held a huge effect but the other
qyz didn't have as much effect I
actually agree with that in fact in my
paper not this one but an earlier one I
wrote with some colleagues we indeed
found that QE one dollar for dollar was
twice as powerful as the other Kiwis and
that is right it was during a crisis it
had really big calming effects on the
market and those events that he's found
big effects but we found that in fact
just looking at what government does
with managing bond supplies in normal
times has an effect you know the debt
management policy and so other studies
of QE in other countries and later on
after the crisis find that it still has
an effect so basically there's a there's
a steady state effect which is not
diminishing it's just pretty constant
and then there's a crisis effect which
is much bigger and that's right but even
though the could steady state effect is
small it's it's it's it's enough to be
worth doing let's see and I think we
could think about doing it in other
assets we focused on government bonds
only I'll come back to that a bit later
so what would I do well I would say we
should probably have a nominal GDP
growth target I have a lot of empathy
sympathy with the market mantra so some
of you may know who think that the feds
main job is really keeping nominal
spending up and growing I would take
target of 5 percent I would do what Ben
said in a zero bound when you hit the
zero bound then you try to make up past
losses and that gives you some more
power of your policy but I would use QE
also at the zero bound acknowledging the
uncertainty still 300 it seems like this
the central core of the estimates for
the u.s. is that 300 billion dollars of
purchases is equivalent to a 25 basis
point cut in the Fed Funds rate that
that's the steady state effect
the prices effect yeah that's uncertain
it's a bit more uncertain as to the
effect on the economy than regular
policy but it's it's our best guess and
it's worth acting on and be nice if the
Fed could do more than just affect the
term premium let's see and then we could
make this systematic this Fed should
just systematically do whatever it needs
to do to achieve its nominal GDP goal
and just focus on that and if you
there's a rule proposed by Lars fencin
and Swedish economist used to be deputy
governor in their Riksbank he thinks
monetary policy should basically always
be set so that your forecast to hit your
goal in about three years you know which
is the sort of the peak point for
monetary policy effectiveness and you
cross validate that with private sector
forecasts and if they agree with you
then maybe you're doing the right thing
I think this may be a way to make it
more systematic now what what are the
lessons learned well I think it's a
little interesting listening to everyone
today that the same large event that was
so important we seem to be learning
different lessons from it so I think
this is very important that we talk
today and that we continue to write to
see see how why is it we're distilling
different lessons from the same events
my sense and this is what Ben also said
is when I look at all the effects of
quantitative easing
they are identical I'm struck by how
identical they are to mock conventional
monetary policy effect on the macro
economy and spending the effect on
international spillover is on the dollar
the effect on the distribution of income
they're all there and they're all worth
talking about but they're no different
from conventional monetary policy it's
just a way of getting past the zero
bound so I don't see any need for
special scrutiny of QE now I would say
in terms of lessons why when we had such
a big QE program and three rounds and
three point six trillion dollars if the
purchases which by the way it's not the
same as a three point six trillion
dollar deficit it's just an asset swap
which is now being unwound
gradually now that we have better
estimates of how QE works our best guess
is that QE one at the time was the
equivalent of a one and a half
percentage point cut in the Fed Funds
rate okay that's significant that's a
big cut but the models the Taylor rule
models that we were using call for
anywhere from a four to A six percent
cut so it was anywhere from a quarter to
a third of the size that our own
economic models said we should do so
then why would we be surprised when we
get a weak recovery I I find this hard
to grasp why people find that a surprise
I was not surprised and as soon as I
left the Fed in the fall of 2009 I was
writing that he was way underpowered and
needed to be a lot bigger and the fact
that the Fed end came around it did more
later in my view sort of proves that
point so far QE has been enormous ly
profitable the Fed has never had such
large profits for a decade now in a row
his profit levels tripled for ten years
in a row running and the Fed has studied
the if welcome to mark the effect on
future profits and what might happen and
there is no realistic scenario in which
Kiwi will cause a loss to the Fed
balance sheet if you accumulate over the
whole program including into the future
now in Europe I think the same result
will be true but I haven't seen studied
in Japan Bank of Japan profits are up
but they're I would recognize that
there's a very real chance Bank of Japan
will lose money over the whole program
when also so yes so anyway so I will not
talk about macro prudential policies I
think they're very important but I don't
think that monetary policy is really the
one that's worth doing okay so final
slide I think I think it would be useful
to let the Fed buy any financial asset
it's the only central bank of a major
economy that doesn't have that
and I don't know why I people talk about
asset allocation and credit distorting
their asset markets it seems to me it's
quite distortionary to force the Fed to
only ever give credit to the federal
government why isn't the neutral policy
one in which the feds portfolio is just
the markets portfolio and let the market
decide how to allocate assets and let
the Fed just follow that seems to me the
natural benchmark and the Fed should
conduct Kiwi in the market basket market
portfolio assets one issue with this
would be it would make the
distributional concerns greater which
some people have raised so my final
point is another option would be to
allow helicopter money I know that's not
Kiwi but Desmond you raised it I
actually think it could work
obviously it raises accountability
issues in our democracy what perhaps
could be done is the Federal Reserve Act
was amended so that the Fed could do
helicopter money under these three
conditions one your policy rate is at
zero and stuck - you're not achieving
you're under achieving your inflation
and employment objectives so you're
below your objectives mandated by
Congress three the Treasury secretary
approves and signs off if those three
conditions are all met then the Fed
would be able to mail out checks to
households and the amount would be set
by the Fed based on what it thinks the
macro economy needs to achieve its goals
mandated by Congress the key thing would
be Congress would determine the
distribution formula is it the same for
every person is it same for every
household is it the proportion of your
previous year's income pat tax what is
it that the Fed should do Congress sets
that but the Fed would then determine
the amount I think this could work and
it would be democratically accountable
and finally I would think it should be
backed by an automatic drawn Treasury
securities so the Fed would balance she
would balance
and that's where I'll leave it there
thank you very much well it's it's
pretty pretty good that we've got
different views Steven you need to go
Alex
close yours thank you very much Desmond
ladies and gentlemen a famous line which
you'll know of John Maynard Keynes is
soon or late it is
ideas which are dangerous for good or
evil and I think a key lesson of
quantitative easing and especially post
crisis quantitative easing is the ideas
of those who run fiat currency central
bank's as these ideas change over time
and go in and out of central bank
fashion are extremely important for good
or evil on a very large scale
indeed now it's interesting to contrast
the ideas of push crisis QE as let me
say parenthetically the Fed was created
to cope with crises that's why it exists
and you do things in crises that you
shouldn't do other times so contrasting
the ideas of post crisis QE to an
earlier set a Federal Reserve governing
ideas as I think quite instructive I
refer to the nineteen fifties and
sixties ideas of the Fed under Chairman
William McChesney Martin where the Fed
adopted a bills what was called the
bills only policy let me remind you what
this meant it meant that the only asset
that the Federal Reserve bought and sold
and held in open market operations work
short-term Treasury bills why did they
think that it's it's hard to imagine
something more completely different as
an idea of a central banker than QE and
especially post crisis QE the reason
they said it was because I think
disagreeing Joe with the point you made
that they thought that was that would
have the least possible impact on the
cost of long-term capital and they also
thought that the Fed should never try to
allocate credit among among various
economic sectors as I said this is
clearly the opposite of the theory of
post crisis QE it's not a policy for a
crisis but it has something to say for
it as a policy for all the rest of the
time like now because of course we are
to use Kevin's words back to peacetime
the crisis has been over for years now
let me ask you how many Treasury bills
does the Fed own today
no the panel knows the answer is zero
zero and it has been for years so over
50 years the ideas of those running the
Fed have gone from believing that only
Treasury bills should be held in their
portfolio to having no Treasury bills of
whatsoever so I take as another lesson
of the QE experience this do not look
for the ideas of central bankers to be
eternal verities they aren't and they
can't be and the credit crunch of 1966
which was created by the feds interest
rate regulations yes the Fed used to
believe in interest rate regulations as
well
mortgage funds dried up savings and
loans then politically powerful believe
it or not were unhappy and many in
Congress wanted the Fed to buy the bonds
of Fannie Mae and the Federal Home Loan
Banks in order of course to support
housing the Fed did not wish to do this
was still a William McChesney Martin
pointed out that this was complete
credit allocation by the Fed he
described it as
diverting open market operations from
general economic objectives to the
support of specific markets for credit
which was exactly what the idea was he
objected that this would violate a
fundamental principle of sound monetary
policy that is it would attempt to use
the credit creating powers of the
central bank to subsidize programs
benefitting special sectors of the
economy and therefore we shouldn't do it
well of course the mortgage-backed part
of QE is precisely credit allocation to
a sector housing however however right
Martin may have been about this I think
he was right it's also the fact that
Congress loves nothing better than to
subsidize an over leveraged real estate
it's their favorite activity and it gets
us into trouble again and again so here
was the message from Congress delivered
by a senator quite prominent in his day
senator Proxmire in a 1968 hearing Kevin
I pick up your thought here about don't
assume that the Fed is institutionally
always the same over time said Proxmire
to the Federal Reserve representative
you'll recognize I take it that the
Federal Reserve Board is a creature of
the Congress that we can create it
abolish it and so forth what would
Congress have to do to indicate that it
wishes the board to change its policy
and give more support to housing well I
presume had senator Proxmire still been
alive today he would be a fan of
permanent QE the new Fed Chairman
beginning in 1970 was not William
McChesney Martin it was Arthur burns and
Arthur burns then considering this
discussion with the Congress came to
believe in his own words that the Fed
should demonstrate a more cooperative
so by the 1980s I think this is very
little-known in fact the feds bond
portfolio evolved to include the debt of
Fannie Mae the Federal Home Loan Banks
the federal Farm Credit banks the
federal land banks the federal
intermediate credit banks the bank for
cooperatives the United States Postal
Service Ginnie Mae the General Services
Administration the Farmers Home
administration the export-import bank
and the Washington Metropolitan Area
Transit Authority that means that the
Fed was funding the Washington DC metro
system a pretty clear example of
favoring a particular economic sector
and look how far this can can get away
along with with helping finance the
subway for Washington the Fed was
financing fannie mae which was insolvent
in those days on a mark-to-market basis
and the utterly broke Farm Credit System
was bonds it was also buying now still
we have to say that at the peak all of
these together only totaled about nine
billion dollars or about 0.2 percent of
the feds current knowledge sheet size so
let's review because we really haven't
talked about the exact numbers of where
the Fed's balance sheet is now as of May
30th Treasury bills zero long-term or
longer-term Treasury securities two
point four trillion mortgage-backed
securities which Carter glass is looking
down from financial valhalla I'm sure
he's got a stomachache still over this
1.8 trillion dollars 1.8 trillion
dollars in mortgages funded with
floating rate deposits
this makes the Fed in effect the biggest
savings and loan in the world maybe in
the crisis we needed the Fed to be the
world's biggest savings and loan do we
know the total assets of
as of May 30th four point three trillion
dollars its total capital is thirty nine
billion dollars giving it a leverage of
a hundred and ten to one probably our
number one among American financial
institutions in that way and this is
again in to use Kevin's term in
peacetime now we know and has been said
these immense portfolios are running
very slowly off they're not being sold
among the other reasons for not selling
is that the Fed doesn't want to face the
very large losses it's super leveraged
balance sheet that it would realize by
selling however much profits they have
may have booked in the past to the
profits base of the losses of selling
would be or could conceivably be many
times the total capital of the Fed and
given these very large potential losses
it is easier to just go into runoff and
have it take very long and the lesson is
it's a lot easier to get into a large QE
programs than to get out of us the exit
strategy and we know the Fed thought
long and carefully about exit strategy
but it's still hard to do is constrained
to be very gradual constraint being the
recognition of losses which they would
not like to do and the gradual strategy
is is combined with the hope that the
adjustment in the very highly inflated
house prices of this country and the
inflated stock and bond prices will also
be gradual well maybe they won't this is
especially true of the inflated house
prices because that of course touches a
much broader swath of American
how this holds since 64 percent of
American households own own their house
and are affected by these prices and
they are in very many cases highly
leveraged so let's move to another QE
lesson and this one I think is it's
absolutely fundamental in principle fiat
currency not not a gold standard central
bank but a fiat currency central bank
can make unlimited investments in
anything
financed by monetization the Federal
Reserve's a champion investor in
mortgages as we've said the european
central bank owns corporate bonds
government agency bonds regional and
local government debt asset backed
securities and covered mortgage bonds
among other things the Bank of Japan
this has been mentioned owns equities
and asset backed securities in addition
to a notion of a Japanese government
debt the Swiss National Bank owns huge
amounts of foreign currency bonds
foreign currency relative to it a huge
portfolio of US equity securities and in
addition loans to the switz one's own
mortgage companies that are sort of like
the Federal Home Loan Banks an
interesting thing to note is that the
Swiss central bank is required to mark
these securities to market and does and
runs them through its profit and loss
statement this is a discipline the
Federal Reserve said jealously avoids
all of these involve all of these
strategies involve credit allocation of
course with the Fed the two allocations
that it is favored our housing of
Senator Proxmire would have been pleased
and financing the government deficit but
the only limits to what a fiat currency
central bank can finance without limit
and can therefore subsidize our
the law and the ideas that govern their
their behavior well what should we be we
be doing now and what should the future
bring to this we might say that whether
there is having said that political
constraints are one of along with ideas
or the constraints on central bankers I
believe the future political constraints
on QE will depend on how the QE
experiment ultimately turns out and that
we don't know because the exit has
barely begun so over time we'll see how
it turns out I said that the the
adjustment is very gradual therefore we
hope for a gradual adjustment in other
words a soft landing but it might be a
hard landing if it's a hard landing you
can imagine the Congress a wanting to
get involved in in reforming the Federal
Reserve with respect to this and all
these things we simply don't know yet
but what should the Fed be doing now
Charles Goodhart that distinguished Dean
of thinking about central banking
recently wrote it's generally agreed
that were the quantitative easing
involve directional elements to support
credit flows through critical but weak
markets for example a mortgage market in
the USA such assets should be entirely
run off leaving the direction to market
forces and the and the assets left in
the central bank's balance sheet should
be entirely in the form of government
debt and with all due respect to the
ghost of Senator Proxmire that seems
right to me but as Goodheart continues
it doesn't answer another big question
which QE makes us ask what is the
optimal size of a central bank's balance
sheet how much QE should there should
there ever be a can and there's another
question can central bank's successfully
practice
credit allocation overtime without
messing things up and further how should
we understand the respective roles of
the Treasury in the central bank is
another way of talking about fiscal
policy or monetary policy are the
Treasury in the central bank really two
things or really only one thing and
further in this country are the Fed the
Treasury and Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
or things or really only one thing well
are all these these questions so I close
with a final lesson of QE which is we
won't know what the final lessons are
until after the exit is completed and
Kevin pointed out history didn't end in
2007 but history never ends in each set
of actions we take
certainly in economics and finance raise
additional new problems that we then
have to address in the future
hey thank you very much Alex I think
that the hour is late you know we've got
something like 10 minutes for questions
I think we'll just take a few questions
from the audience if anybody's got a
question if they could just raise their
hand and somebody will bring a mic to
you and I'll take a few questions and
then just pass that on to the panelists
thank you let's take another question
this gentleman he was alluded to by the
last speaker but when do we know when QD
is QE QE has ended are there any other
questions okay so I was just wondering
if we could learn from the experience of
other countries where it seemed like the
ones that kind of dragged their feet on
it in particular the euro area you know
they seemed like their last ones in and
they're gonna end up being you know some
of the longest you know lasting programs
as a result okay so would you like to
sure all right I'll take the first and
the third question if that'd be good um
and in fact they're related and I like
the way you put it
by the way when QE first happened to
central bank's went in quickly
relatively boldly although I would argue
in hindsight not boldly enough but given
the uncertainties it was a reasonable
thing that we did and two central bank's
hung back and I think they needed it but
they didn't do it and that was your ECB
in Japan and I think that lesson I
learned from that is that if you are
timid the more timid you are in an in an
environment of growing deflationary
expectations or disinflation or
expectations that get entrenched it
makes your job in the future harder
because you're gonna have to go against
these entrenched disinflation or
expectations and that is hard and it's
better quit before that gets set in so I
do think that what you said is exactly
right because they were slow to enter
they're actually going to be doing much
more than they would have had to do
otherwise and doing it much longer and
that to me is a lesson I learned and in
particular on Japan
and yeah I think Japan is really where
the limits of Kiwi are to be seen
because they have 10-year bond yields at
zero literally zero I never thought that
was possible if you would ask me 10
years ago I wouldn't have believed it
was possible it can't go any further I
mean you could just hold $100 bills in a
safe and get a better return than a
10-year jgb so why would you ever hold
it so that is the limit of Kiwi in that
space now I think they could do some
more equity they're doing a bit of
equity that could do more the central
bank of Hong Kong actually did a very
large equity purchase in 1998 in a
crisis and it had wonderful good effects
and they were able to get out of it
successfully so it was an example of a
Kili exit by the way that that we did
see that worked now there's no guarantee
that it's always going to work if you do
QE without a strategy without a
disciplined framework the way senator
Proxmire was was urging people to do and
you slowly get in and you have no idea
what you're doing or what the limits are
the goals are that's a disaster you have
to have a sense what is you what are you
trying to achieve and you stop when you
achieve it and I fear that Japan has
come too late to that they now have a
better framework but boy those low
inflation expectations are so entrenched
I think the only answer for them would
have been for a joint government a
fiscal monetary program that included
wage increases for all government
workers with a plea to the private
sector to do the same and then monetize
that to get back to inflationary
expectations of 2% that is the only
thing that I think could work and they
haven't done yet I just
I might just raise a question is that
Joe seems to think that long-term
interest rates there's a flaw at zero
but there's something like 13 trillion
dollars of sovereign bonds you know for
instance like Germany and so on that are
trading at negative interest rates you
know long-term you know that my
be one of the distortions that we've had
from quantitative easing but let me ask
Kevin you know just to comment because
it seems like the big disagreement
between Kevin and Joe is that Kevin
seems to think that it's very important
not to distort prices particularly of a
very important asset like the 10-year
bond and you seem to be concerned about
a surprise inflation and the credit
spreads beginning to compress Joe seems
to be rather relaxed about all of that I
mean of course we'll have a seminar when
all of this comes to an end the gun
wondering but in anticipation of the
seminar just thought you might want to
elaborate on your concern sure
so thank you so a couple things first
Joe is brilliant and we were incredibly
fortunate I say this with all sincerity
I have colleagues like him with us in
the crisis that blue sky thinking we
were doing in Ben's office hour after
hour was informed by the brilliance of
about 20 fed economists and so some of
these ideas that he put forth today
which I consider sheer madness we're
quite interesting and useful to force us
to think so so while I disagree with him
on a lot of things this is what the
institution's supposed to be this is
what separates the Fed from dare I say
other institutions across the United
States government to have that kind of
open thinking and rigorous discussion he
called his paper QE and underappreciated
success well it seems as though I would
describe it somewhat differently it is a
success it is a great triumph for those
of us assembled in this room missus
really couldn't have worked out better
for all of us couldn't it so if you
happen to own financial assets I really
can't find a better way to have us all
improve our relative net worth the only
problem is 52 percent of our fellow
Americans have no financial assets and
we wonder why and how has happened to
our politics now to the question that
that Desmond that you asked about price
setting and the rest
I'll say two things first I am
open-minded these cross-country
comparisons but the United States is
different than the rest of the world
that has been since 1946 the
productivity we've driven the increase
in standards of living
not because we're clones of anyone else
but because we practiced a different
kind of economics and politics really
through the most recent era so often in
these discussions often when I was at
the Fed what we would hear from
colleagues who are incredibly learned is
if you don't do this you'll be Japan
well that's more of an ad hominem attack
than it is a deep understanding the way
I'll state that simply is the micro
foundations of macro are essential and
they diverge markedly between the United
States and our trading partners around
the world these comparisons I think
offer far less than meets the eye
finally on the question of price setting
and the rest if you don't know what the
10-year risk-free rate is it is
impossible to value any asset anywhere
in the world because we would take that
risk free rate set in open markets as
would everyone in other countries they
would add term premia credit premium
inflation premium liquidity premium and
the rest and so I think it's asking
ourselves for tail risks if we can't be
certain of what that risk-free rate is
this is why historically even as the Fed
wandered away from a bills only policy
we decided that we did not want to go
all the way out in the yield curve
unless exigent circumstances dictate it
because we believe that that risk-free
rate really mattered none of us know
what that risk-free rate should be and
finally I'll just say we have heard a
discussion today and you hear it very
commonly about this low trend growth and
now people are championing this low
trend growth that we've had of 2%
between 2010 to 2016 what's funny um
Desmond in 2009 the Fed started making
public our forecasts and in 2009 we did
not think we were in a crisis we've
forecasted the GDP growth in 2010 would
be four and a half percent 2010 we
predicted that the economy would grow in
2011
or point 2 percent and now the story
we're told is oh it was demographics was
productivity
you know the secular stagnation is real
we need to lower expectations the only
thing we actually can forecast is
demography and if that's really the
story then the Fed has quite a lot to
account for for why we thought there
would be a rosy scenario then if it
didn't have something to do with actual
conduct of public policy in the last
word I'd like to answer the gentleman's
question about when we know QE is over I
think it's a very relevant question I'd
say it'll be over for the Federal
Reserve when the Federal Reserve owns no
mortgages no mortgage-backed securities
and when at least half of its Treasury
securities are short term bills and not
notes and bonds it'll be over for the
Swiss National Bank when it has fully
liquidated its portfolio of US stocks
and similarly I'd say for other for the
other central banks maybe maybe you mean
that it'll be over when the leopard lies
with the lab on that note I just want to
thank my panelists and assure you that
when something big happens on this
quantitative easing saga we'll convene
to discuss it again
[Applause]
[Music]
we love that are you